Jill Wesley, thank you so much
for joining my show, 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm doing great.
Thanks for having me.
How have you helped 80,000 people
become better speakers
and convey their messages?
How is that humanly possible?
How is it humanly possible?
Well, I've done it for almost 30 years
and the number actually
is higher than 85,000.
It's because I was a road warrior
for a really long time.
And I did management leadership training,
I did coaching and personal development
and professional development programs
for leaders and employees.
So, we did communication,
intercultural communication
and speaker coaching.
So, I was on the road for a long time
working with thousands
and thousands of people.
What does that mean, working on the road?
It means, literally, being on the road
moving between company and company
and working physically with them?
I was, I used to be one of those.
My 20s were spent
traveling around the world
doing it a part time backpacker.
And then I would land in a country
make something work, save money,
and then go spend it
and travel some more.
But then in my 30s,
I did corporate training and coaching,
So, I worked as a consultant.
So, a number of years I was on the road
maybe a hundred days a year.
Hundreds days a year?
[--] all over the world.
Yeah, it was a lot.
Give me a little bit of taste.
What were some of the craziest places
that this work took you
or craziest experiences?
Crazy experience?
Well, all the experiences were later
you learn with time.
Time and distance equals humor.
So, a lot of the crazy
really difficult things that went on,
later became the best stories.
I always tell my clients that
when they're putting
their keynotes together.
But there were times where
I showed up to do a speaking gig
and there was no room for us
or I had a fistfight one time
in a session.
But in terms of location,
Just casually putting them in there
and continuing, I love it.
I said that too casually.
But when it's human behavior
and you get a group of people together,
it's a human lab and anything's possible.
I didn't start the fight.
But I'm just saying,
like anything can happen.
But in terms of actual locations,
I've just been really honored
to work all over Asia and Europe
and then a few three months in Australia,
working at 23, I got to work at
eight major universities in Australia.
I didn't work that hard,
it was fun and distracting and sunny.
Unbelievable. Okay.
So, I had the privilege of giving
a TEDx talk in Palo Alto
about, I guess, it was five years ago.
It was hard.
It was a process.
It was really really difficult.
Not just getting up on stage,
which is frightening for any person
no matter how much you're building,
you'll be scared.
But the whole process is very difficult.
Why is giving keynotes
or presentations so hard?
Well, it's hard for a number of reasons.
If it's a business presentation,
the average person
can be challenged with it
because there's a lot riding on it.
It's the reputation at work,
it's moving a process forward at work,
it's getting your ideas heard,
or helping people make big decisions.
So, a lot of people know
that there is a lot at stake
and they feel nervous.
If someone's doing a keynote,
it's usually the combination
of their work experience
plus a bit of their thought leadership
or personal brand.
My day to day is spent with senior leaders
who have a track record of success.
So, by the time they're on stage
and we are working together
at major events, part of it is,
oh my gosh, I've been so good
as a presenter at work all these years.
Now, I don't want to mess it up
when I know millions of people are good.
So, what I always remind people is,
it's a process.
There's no finish line.
Everybody is going to hit a wall
and feel nervous.
I joke, it is my clients
usually at one point are thinking like,
"How do I get out of doing this talk?"
"What if I just tell them I'm sick?"
"What if I go
in the witness protection program?"
All these fantasies
of not having to do it.
But my job as a coach is
to just let them know
that's a normal process,
it's the messy middle.
And I actually have a process
to get them from start to finish.
I like that, the messy middle.
That this idea that at some point
throughout the process
you're going to reach this block
where you say, okay, I'm not prepared yet,
it's not ready yet.
And you forget that
there are a few days left
or a few weeks left
and you're, I guess, imagining yourself,
giving the talk as it is now,
even though that's not the reality.
You still have time, right?
You still have time.
But tell me about this process
that you work
because it's so fascinating to me.
Because obviously it is.
I believe that
the fear of public speaking,
if I'm not mistaken,
is more common than fear of death.
I think it's the [--].
We haven't sourced that research.
So, it's often quoted.
It is a common fear, I'll put it that way.
To this day, I'm not sure
if I've heard anybody actually
dying from public speaking.
So, most people,
But it's death itself is very existential.
But the fear that we experience
and the nerves giving a talk is real
and it's likely and it happens
over and over again.
So for most people, it's a concern
that on a cellular level for people,
there's a concern that
they're going to be judged,
that they're going to fail.
Yes.
And your body is registering
an actual threat
and it's trying to protect you.
So, what a lot of people
don't realize is
when they're feeling nervous,
they will then criticize themselves
for feeling nervous:
I can't believe it,
I told myself
I wouldn't feel this way;
or I've been doing this
for five years, why.
And that self-criticism
never makes the nerves go away
that's number one.
Number two, reframing it from:
I'm feeling like I'm going to die
and my body's betraying me.
If you understand that your body
is actually having a response
and it's doing what it thinks
it needs to do to help you
and then reframing it
from nervous to excitement.
Most of my clients, I will say,
the keynote clients that I work with
are not terribly nervous.
They're excited.
They've been speaking for years,
and in business or science
for a number of years.
So, they're hungry and they're excited.
And my job is to pull them out
to get more of them into their talk.
So, it's not just their data,
not just their work.
So, what makes a successful keynote?
Whether it's a business keynote
that's full of data and statistics,
or if it's more of a personal keynote
about your personal journey
or about how others can get inspiration
from your journey.
So, give me some ideas of what makes
a successful keynote.
Yeah, I put it, I call them the three R's.
So, the measure of a really
successful presentation or talk
isn't did everybody jump up
and do a standing ovation,
because that's an experience
in the moment.
But I really care about what happens
when people leave.
So, the three things are the three R's:
Is your content relatable.
So, for far too long,
people have gotten up on stage
and spoken from a place
or a perspective
that was not taking into account
the different lived experiences
of people of color like me
or women's experiences in work and life.
So, is the content relatable,
And do you truly understand
and respect your audience,
were you putting content together
that relates to them.
Number two, is your content
something that people can remember.
So, you have to relate.
Can people remember it,
meaning it's structured effectively
that you're not doing a total data dump
or you're telling a personal story
that takes 17 minutes
that isn't relevant to the audience.
And then the third piece is,
can people repeat it.
Because a lot of my clients
actually create movements.
They're working at really high levels.
If we're going to create systemic change
or cultural change movement type work,
people have to be able to repeat
what they heard to serve others.
So, those are the three things
I talk about.
And how do you measure that?
So, I gave a talk and I went off of stage,
and yeah, it's on YouTube
and we have the views.
How do I actually measure
whether my talk was successful
and according to these three R's?
Yeah. It depends on the industry
and the type of speaker I'm working with.
So, yes, of course,
it's great to have those metrics
and see that one of my clients talks,
is it three million, that's fabulous.
However, the folks that I'm working with
are already head down doing the deep work
and they happen to be
on stage talking about it.
So, the metrics that
we're actually looking at
is did they get funding,
was there an increase in funding.
It's a business development tool
where they able to get
some key relationships
that help them with their research
where they able to align
and get connections with policymakers.
So, it's much more tangible
beyond the applause
or the [--].
I think it's incredible.
I'm coming from the software world.
And in the software world
when we launch, for example, our product
there's a couple of ways of looking at it.
One is you put up the website
and you want to measure
how many good impressions have you had,
how many people have gone and seen
your beautifully designed logo
and you're beautiful website.
And then the question is,
how many people actually
put their credit card and paid.
How many people actually converted
to paying customers, which is obviously,
what you're optimizing for.
You're not optimizing
for how many people have seen it.
You're optimizing for how many people
have bought into your messaging.
And that brings me on
to a set of questions that I have.
Because going through this experience,
you watch all these incredible talk
whether it's on TED
or all these different platforms.
And a lot of people are wondering as well,
myself included,
how much are they improvised
in the moment,
authentic versus very rehearsed?
Because a lot of them
feel extremely improvised,
very lively in the moment,
but there is a lot of preparation
that goes in there.
So, how do you balance between the two?
Yeah. So, that's good
that a lot of them feel improvised to you.
Because the bigger events,
so I'm head of speaker coaching
for TEDx San Francisco,
so we have a premier event, global event,
and our speaker, there's no way
we're going to let people
just go up there and wing it.
It's just not in the process.
They won't present
their best content that way
and the audience
won't have the best experience.
We can't just take that risk.
And TED itself,
because I've coached speakers
that have spoken on TED stages,
they worked together with coaches
for months and months.
So, the goal is when people get
where they get stuck is
I don't want to sound canned,
I don't want to sound rehearsed
and like I'm a robot,
I don't want that either.
But there's a difference between
memorizing a talk and then actually,
integrating that talk into who you are.
And that's the difference
if you're thinking about
someone who's an actor.
An actor will know their lines.
But a really good actor
disappears into the character
and they're having that experience
with the audience.
So, I'm different from some other coaches
because my job is to meet my clients
where they are.
I have a ton of strategy in my pocket.
So, if I'm working with someone
who I know is the type that
really needs to write their speech out
word for word,
and they're really attached to that,
I'll let them do that initially
but I'm always going to get them
from it's not memorizing word for word,
it's just knowing the flow.
And if it's someone
who likes to be loose
and be improvisational,
I still get them to know the flow.
So then, they're going to practice.
They've practiced at multiple times
with their space
in the event that the audience will laugh.
I mean, I put a lot of help my clients
put humor in their talks
and you will get a response
from the audience
or you'll get spontaneous applause.
So, you have to be present
to actually engage with people
in that moment.
It's hilarious to bring this up.
So, I gave a talk back when I was 14,
it was my second time on stage.
It was about to start up in real time.
I had nothing interesting to say
except for how a 14 year old uses Skype
to do a video call with their math class
from 15,000 miles away.
Back then, it was 10 years ago,
it wasn't very common.
So, it was interesting to the people
in the audience.
But what the funny thing was that
I prepared so much for this talk.
I am releasing a book soon
where I talk about
some childhood experiences
and one of the experiences
was walking around Central Park
with my brother.
And he is rehearsing with me
word for word my speech,
my talk for weeks.
And leading up to the talk,
I knew it so well
I could say it in the middle of my sleep.
I get to the stage
and my first question is,
"Hey, how's everybody doing?"
Now, when I rehearsed this talk,
I never actually gave pause
because there was nobody to answer.
So, when I got on stage, I said,
"Hey, how everybody is doing?"
"Great, let's get started."
And I never gave them a way to answer
which was it's hilarious.
That's what happens. It is.
I see a keynote in particular
as a living thing.
So, very similar to you in product,
I think of a keynote, for my clients,
it's a product launch.
So, it's an iterative process.
We use universal design theory.
We have to test.
You have to do all of those steps
that you would do with product
to make sure that
whatever you create and deliver
is truly something to your best,
the best of your ability
is something that the audience
is going to relate to and respond.
But you have to take notes
once you've done your keynote
or you have to watch the film afterwards
to see what really landed
and pay attention
to the questions you get at
in the comments afterwards
because it will inform this keynote.
Because I help people deliver
and excuse me, design an asset
that they're going to keep using.
So, nobody is going to be giving
the same exact keynote over and over
to audience after audience
because you're in a different city.
You're talking to people
in different roles, different levels
within an organization.
You'd have to make it tie in
to what their lived experiences.
100%.
So, in the few minutes we have left,
I'd love some pointers
on things that I could take with me
to whatever future presentations I make,
or at least the process of working
on those presentations.
Because obviously,
not everybody is so lucky
to have you as a coach
in preparing for their keynote.
And I'd love to get some pointers
into what can I do the next time I go
to present something to my boss
in the startup that I work for,
what can my friends do
when they're about to go in class
and present something
in front of 500 people on their research?
Sure.
I have a five step process I use
called, dig deeper.
Because you can come in 10 minutes,
10 seconds, you can find the steps
to give a general presentation.
You analyze your audience,
you get your big message together
and support it with
and then put in action step.
But something deeper
that I use as a checklist
with senior leaders is five steps.
So first, you have to speak the truth.
So, it's really figuring out
what is my truth,
my understanding of the truth,
and do I have an accurate sense
of what's actually going on.
Because if you're presenting,
let's say it's someone whose entry level
or middle management
and they're presenting to their boss
and they're not accurate,
it's a credibility hit right there.
So, make sure that
you really have the truth
and you are acknowledging
your blind spots and biases.
Second, it's empathy.
And it's not just empathy
for what other people are feeling,
but having a sense of cognitive empathy.
So, it's what are other people
thinking about.
And a bit of what's called
rational compassion,
because there are limits to empathy.
We tend to empathize the most
with people who are similar to us.
Yeah.
Or if we've had a similar experience
where we say,
"Well, I did it,
it shouldn't be that hard."
"Just work hard, you can do it yourself."
And it's like, listen,
someone's having a different life journey
than you are.
So, it's truth.
It's empathy.
And then, really thinking about,
do you have an element of hope
when you're talking,
are you speaking in a way
where people feel like they can do this,
that it's not beyond everybody's ability.
The fourth step is your vision.
So, what do you see as possible
and can you communicate it in a way
that other people can actually
be there right with you.
And then the last step,
which is huge, is accountability.
Accountability is missing from most talks.
They are real general things
at the end of a presentation or a talk.
And people just be really general like,
"You can do it, come on."
And if people can't get a clear grasp
of what needs to be done,
those initial steps,
they're less likely to do anything.
And that's why people go
from event to event to event
to get pumped up
and that they don't know
how to actually do it.
So, they're chasing the high
of being in the room versus, oh, wait,
I want to make some behavioral change.
It actually takes strategy and have it.
I like the accountability.
Jill, why spend so much time on this?
Why work with so many speakers?
Why go through all of this?
What gets you excited
about science and soul of speaking?
Oh, my gosh.
I have the best job in the world.
Like, I'm truly doing
the thing I love to do most.
My work doesn't feel like work at all.
At all.
And I stand on the shoulders of people
who came before me.
I'm African-American.
I come from generations of people
who weren't able to use their voice.
And I'm fortunate to have that luck.
Yeah, I've worked hard,
but it's luck and timing.
I was born when I was born
and I feel that everyone deserves
the ability to speak their truth
and know what matters.
And that's why I do this work.
I love it.
Before we leave,
I want to thank you again
for being so generous of your time.
This was just wonderful,
insightful, inspiring.
I just loved it.
And I'll definitely look forward
to reflecting on this talk
as I continue on in my journey
and hopefully collaborate together one day
if I'm ever fortunate enough
to make it to those big stages
that you help people on.
Before we leave, Jill,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself
and why those three specific words.
Okay. Well,
I've been inside the house for months, so,
I mean, my initial three words are like
yoga pants, potato chips, and TV.
But if we go a little bit deeper,
the first one is commitment.
I'm really committed
to doing the work I do
and helping people.
It's curiosity.
I've always been curious
and willing to challenge myself
to keep my mind open.
And then collaborative.
Because nobody gets ahead on their own.
And it's really about working together.
And if you get into a big room
and you get through that door,
it's keeping that door open
and waving other people into.
I love it.
Jill, thank you very very much.
This is just wonderful.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you.
My pleasure. Thanks.